bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et voici
le sommaire de ce 5 septembre des
scientifiques qui disent leur ras-le-bol
face au manque d'ambition des réformes
gouvernementales et des actions menées
par les entreprises pour lutter contre
les dérèglements climatiques et pourtant
l'été en France et en Europe a encore
prouvé l'urgence
les événements un truc extrême leur
intensité leur fréquence et leur durée
et quand on parle de d'événements
climatiques extrêmes on parle de la
canicule qu'on subit aujourd'hui mais
aussi des inondations des cyclones des
mégafeux et ben cette intensité cette
fréquence et cette durée va être
exacerbée par le changement climatique
provoqué par les activités humaines
faut-il changer de modèle économique
voire de civilisation pour limiter le
réchauffement à 1 degré et demi ou deux
degrés ce sera notre premier débat juste
après ces titres et puis dans 45 minutes
c'est l'offensive menée par Emmanuel
Macron et son ministre de l'Éducation
autour des valeurs d'autorité de laïcité
et de civisme que l'on va analyser
interdiction des abayas enseignement
chronologique de l'histoire
expérimentation de l'uniforme le
président de la République a-t-il une
vision passéiste de l'école comme le dit
certains syndicats de prof on en débat
dans 45 minutes mais d'abord donc cet
été européen de record de température et
de catastrophes écologique racontée par
Samia le chien
la journée d'hier est la plus chaude
jamais enregistrée en France au mois de
septembre
25,1 degré en moyenne sur le territoire
avec des pics à 37 degrés une vague de
chaleur qui succède à une autre canicule
toute récente fin août le mercure à
grimper à des niveaux jamais atteints
dans plusieurs villes
43,2 degrés à Carcassonne et plus de 42
à Toulouse ou orange
le record absolu de température ont été
battus pendant cet événement donc
effectivement il y a pas d'équivalent
d'un événement aussi chaud aussi tard en
saison
dans le passé tout ça est très cohérent
avec le tableau clinique du changement
climatique tel que décrit par le GIEC
par exemple depuis déjà un certain
nombre de rapports partout les
événements climatiques extrêmes se
multiplient depuis lundi depuis
torrentielles s'abattent sur la Grèce
déjà touchée c'était par des incendies
meurtriers qui ont ravagé 150 000
hectares plus torrentiel également en
Espagne qui ont déjà fait deux morts et
trois disparus plus le climat se
réchauffe plus ces épisodes seront
nombreux si dans quelques décennies est
atteint 2 3 degrés à chaque fois ce sont
des événements plus intenses et plus
fréquents et donc éventuellement qui qui
vont rendre relativement banal les
niveaux de température observer seul
levier d'action pour limiter l'intensité
de ces événements climatiques extrêmes
une réduction drastique et rapide des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
le ras-le-bol des scientifiques des
climatologues notamment face à la
lenteur au manque d'ambition des
politiques et des milieux économiques
face à l'urgence écologique voilà le
thème de notre débat j'accueille Jean
jauzel bonsoir bonsoir Thomas bienvenue
à tous vous êtes climatologue ancien
vice-président du GIEC le groupe
d'experts sur l'évolution du climat
Flora Gaby bonsoir bienvenu à vous aussi
vous êtes entrepreneur dans la
transition écologique vous conseiller
les les entreprises dans leur
transformation vous êtes essayiste et
auteur de ce livre le syndrome de la
fourmi aux éditions de l'Observatoire
j'accueille également Mathieu goharb
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous vous êtes
journaliste en charge de ces questions
climatiques au quotidien Le Monde et
Laetitia cruppa bonsoir vous retrouver
sur ce plateau éditorialiste politique
je commence par un constat en vient d'en
faire un avec Samia Dechy en mais il est
tout récent celui de la journée d'hier
de ce lundi 4 septembre journée la plus
chaude pour un mois de septembre depuis
1949 près de 200 records de chaleur
battus dans toute la France
près de 40 degrés 39 degrés 3 à l'ombre
dans la Vienne c'était hier genre je
vous aime je pense que vous répondez à
cette question depuis depuis des
semaines des mois des années il va
falloir s'y habituer malheureusement oui
il va falloir s'y habitué donc Mathieu
en a fait un excellent compte-rendu dans
le monde aujourd'hui disons il y a le
bilan de l'été 2023 qui vient d'être
publié par Météo France et c'est
effectivement c'est la quatrième le
quatrième été le plus chaud que nous
ayons connu et on redit de que les étés
les plus chauds sont évidemment les étés
du 21e siècle ça va se dire qu'ils vont
devenir la norme en quelque sorte oui ça
a été très bien dit dans cette dans
cette intervention les étés que nous
connaissons actuellement
sont à partir de 2050 mais moi ce que
j'aimerais dire c'était dit de façon
disons un peu rapide là c'est que ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
ce que des rapports successifs du GIEC
envisagent depuis en particulier pour
les anneaux extrêmes depuis la fin des
années alors c'est vrai en termes
d'intensification développement extrême
mais c'est vrai aussi en termes par
exemple d'accélération de l'élévation du
niveau de la mer le niveau de la mer
disons célèbre deux fois plus rapidement
au cours des dix dernières années qu'au
cours de la 50 dernières années du du
dernier siècle et ça c'était prévu c'est
vrai aussi pour le rythme lui-même du
réchauffement climatique et ça doit
vraiment nous inviter je le répète à
accorder de la crédibilité à ce que dit
notre communauté à échéance de 2050 et
au-delà c'est un message très fort mais
franchement on a beaucoup de mal à faire
comprendre que ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui va décider du climat de la
seconde partie du 21e siècle on va
évidemment détailler moi je dis
ras-le-bol ou bon je sais pas quel terme
vous employez-vous face à cette
situation mais ce sera vraiment le thème
central de Zeba on va donner la parole
tient prévisionniste de Météo France
tout de suite toujours sur cette
succession de d'épisodes caniculaire on
les compare sur plusieurs dizaines de
décennies écoutons
alors on s'attend puisqu'on l'a déjà
observé effectivement une multiplication
des canicules sur à peu près les 70
dernières années il y a trois fois plus
de canicule dans les 35 dernières années
que dans les 35 années précédentes donc
dans le contexte du réchauffement
climatique il est logique que les
phénomènes de type canicule et vagues de
chaleur et tendance à devenir plus
fréquent Mathieu est-ce que il y a eu
une partie de l'été marquée par des
températures basses pas mal de pluie
donc toute une partie nord de la France
est-ce que c'est plus difficile de faire
de faire passer
je dis ça parce qu'on a tous entendu des
amis malheureusement nous dire bah
attends arrête de me parler parce que
moi je prêche cette cette parole là
auprès de tous mes proches arrête de
nous parler de réchauffement climatique
tu as vu il était pourri qu'on a dans le
Nord ou en Bretagne est-ce que c'est
plus difficile pour nous journaliste
parle de votre responsabilité de notre
responsabilité médiatique du coup il y a
un effet de contraste très fort qui a
des conséquences sur l'opinion française
c'est vrai qu'on a eu une fin de mois de
juillet et d'un début de mois d'août
très très disons tempéré même avec du
mauvais temps sur tout le quart
nord-ouest de la France contrairement
aux été 2019-2022 qui avait été des été
très chauds aussi où il avait fait chaud
dans toute la France très tôt dans la
saison du coup une partie des Français
peuvent se dire c'est vrai le
réchauffement climatique cet été j'ai eu
beaucoup de pluie le problème avec les
questions climatiques c'est l'importance
et de prendre du recul et c'est vraiment
d'analyser le climat et global il
concerne tous les pays il faut analyser
l'été de l'hémisphère Nord en fait et il
y en a eu une accumulation d'événements
extrêmes dans l'hémisphère nord la ville
de Phoenix au Texas a connu 31 jours à
plus de 43 degrés on parle de 31 jours
de suite à plus de 43 degrés il a fait
entre 53 et 54 degrés dans la bête de la
mort toujours aux États-Unis et ça
concerné en même temps l'Europe puisque
tout mois de juillet et une très très
grosse canicule sur l'ensemble de
l'Europe c'est la plus longue canicule
qui a connu la Grèce et en Asie en même
temps la Chine a connu est température à
52 53 degrés
et ça a provoqué des événements extrêmes
les feux de forêt au Canada etc on a si
on mélange
faut dézoomer dans le temps et dans
l'espace dans le temps prendre la
dimension et il faut revenir sur la
France tout simplement sur les
statistiques françaises on a eu une
canicule qui est passionnante d'un point
de vue climat et qui est très inquiétant
c'est celle entre le 17 et le 24 août
Jean Jaurès
ont tous lu au 21e siècle les 7
canicules après le 15 août ont toute lu
au 21e siècle aussi et celle entre le 17
et le 24 août était impressionnante
parce qu'elle a battu des records
mensuels dans plein de villes des
records absolus dans beaucoup de villes
et en fait c'est une période après le 15
août où les nuits sont plus longues et
les moyens de température doivent être
beaucoup plus basses normalement on
commence à sortir tout doucement de
l'été après le 31
jours de canicule parce que 17 24 c'est
7 jours de 7 jours de canicule en
globale sur la partie concernée sur
certaines régions ça a été deux semaines
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes PACA a connu
pratiquement deux semaines de
[Musique]
parfois il faut être un peu cynique vous
voyez ce que je veux dire un chef
d'entreprise si vous faites rien voilà
ce qui va vous donner bien sûr alors
certains oui mais je peux pas vous dire
oui non mais évidemment il y a on peut
pas globaliser ça constitue pas une
majorité loin de là et je crois que les
universités du Medef l'ont prouvé c'est
à dire que Patrick pouyanet et davantage
applaudit que jean-jauël qu'est-ce que
ça dit de notre époque et de la
direction qu'on prend sur les chaleurs
de cet été même si alors il y a ceux qui
étaient en vacances dans un endroit où
il sait pas si chaud qui ont dit bon bah
il fait pas si chaud mais il y a ceux
aussi qui ont ce sont dit bon bah il
fait chaud mais c'est supportable il
faudrait faire attention à pas laisser
l'idée que en fait bon bah on va mettre
des climatiseurs il fera 35 à 40 degrés
15 jours par an et en fait ça ne
changera rien et je j'ai peur que le
nouveau risque en ce moment ce soit ça
ce soit de dire bon bah on va s'adapter
37 degrés 15 jours par an si on peut
continuer à confirmer comme on consomme
et à vivre comme on vit c'est
supportable et moi cet été j'en profite
d'être assise à côté d'un journaliste du
Monde j'ai quelqu'un qui m'a dit oh je
romps mon abonnement au monde parce que
il me rappelle tous les jours la météo
et je suis pas là pour voir la météo et
j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu la limite
enfin moi j'ai écrit un essai sur les
barrières mentales de l'inaction
écologique donc vraiment j'essaye de
comprendre ces barrières mentales de et
là ça m'a un peu poussé dans mes limites
quoi je me suis dit là je sais plus
quelle est l'équilibre comment il faut
alerter est-ce que il faut alarmer
est-ce qu'il faut au contraire donner un
projet alternatif à un moment je suis
désolé tout a été fait toutes les
stratégies cohabites et le résultat
n'est toujours pas là et c'est ça qu'il
faut dire je crois mais donc on touche
effectivement à ce blues ce ras-le-bol
des scientifiques que vous avez exprimé
effectivement en revenant de cet
université du Medef je veux bien que
vous nous l'avez peut-être déjà raconté
plusieurs fois mais donc vous vous
retrouvez face
comprends pas trop de Total énergie
Patrick pouillané avec quoi une
difficulté j'emploie des mots peut-être
c'est une litote mais à le convaincre ou
presque c'est quoi c'est comment vous
l'avez ressenti oui une table ronde ou
d'une bataille du Crémont le PDG d'EDF
la ministre espagnolac et puis aussi
Bertrand Picard qui est plus orienté
vers les solutions donc on m'invite
effectivement à ils ont à ouvrir cette
table ronde énergie climat je dirais de
façon assez simple effectivement j'ai
trois minutes pour faire un état des
lieux et voilà donc c'était des lieux
très clair redire qu'il ne reste plus
que 5 ans d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serrurythme d'aujourd'hui si on voulait
limiter avoir des chances de rester
disons autour de 1 degré 5 une quinzaine
d'années au maximum pour 2 degrés et
puis effectivement j'ai terminé en
disant que j'étais en face finalement
avec
l'appel d'Antonio guterese qui invite
finalement à des gens à arrêter les
investissements dans le combustible
fossile et effectivement il y a urgence
et ce n'est ce que nous faisons puisque
nous augmentons les nous continuons à
augmenter nos émissions et
Patrick polonais a rebondi il n'a pas
mis du tout en cause ce que j'ai dit en
termes de sur le sur les sur le constat
certainement pas mais effectivement en
gros il a dit oui mais ça ils ont ça
augmente aussi en France et il s'en est
pas du tout ému il aurait pu dire
effectivement j'ai dit que les émissions
augmentaient le chef planétaire elle est
dit ça augmente aussi en France cette
année quand je dis pas qu'ils sont des
réjouis je veux pas du tout être mais
faisant il y a pas eu il y a il sait pas
du tout interrogé par rapport à disons à
ce qu'il est en train de faire alors
c'est c'est intéressant ce que vous
racontez parce que il y a eu des
réactions nombreuses à très après le
récit le premier récit vous avez fait en
revenant de ces universités d'été
notamment celle du nouveau président du
Ménès Patrick Martin on est on est
vraiment au cœur de ce débat sur notre
capacité à sortir de notre dépendance
aux énergies fossiles écoutons Patrick
Martin
quand je regarde qui sont les gros
investisseurs à travers le monde dans
les énergies renouvelables je pense que
Total tient largement son rang le propos
le propos de Patrick pouyanet que
beaucoup d'entre nous partagent c'est
que il faut que nous soyons réalistes
j'insiste pas sur les finalités pas sur
les calendriers mais sur les modalités
et dire à l'opinion publique française
alors que 75% de notre consommation
d'énergie est à ce jour d'origine
hydrocarbures dire demain matin on
arrête ça pose un vrai sujet pratique et
ça pose un vrai sujet d'acceptabilité
à cet université d'été du Medef et à
d'autres les depuis une petite décennie
c'est ça est-ce que vous avez vu
l'impression d'un coup d'un coup sur le
frein parce que moi je j'anime aussi une
émission sur la transformation
environnementale et sociétale sur une
chaîne économique bispargne pour ne pas
la nommer il y a quand même un mouvement
en tout cas c'est le sentiment que que
j'ai est-ce que vous avez eu là
l'impression qu'il y avait un voilà
un mouvement de recul parce que ce que
je disais agent je vous aime avoir
l'émission j'ai que 10 ans d'expérience
dans le militantisme écologique donc
c'est vraiment pas beaucoup par rapport
à vous mais c'est vrai que je vais
chaque année pour mon travail aux
rencontres aux universités du Medef et
j'avais naïvement cru jusqu'à présent
que le la conviction écologique c'était
une une pente ascendante trop lente pas
assez significative mais que quand même
d'une année sur l'autre on progressé et
le sentiment que j'ai eu tout au long de
la journée qui était assez angoissant
c'est qu'en fait c'est pas c'est pas une
plante ascendante c'est les montagnes
russes c'est à dire que ça monte et ça
descend et j'ai entendu un journaliste
dans une matinale dire le mot de la
rentrée cette année le mot de la rentrée
l'an dernier c'était le mot sobriété il
était dans toutes les bouches et cette
année ce n'est plus le mot sobriété
c'est le mot autorité et je me suis dit
mais ce sera notre second débat sur
l'école mais évidemment qu'on peut
c'est une tendance on dit que le budget
des armées ça fait consensus parce que
c'est inévitable pour nous protéger il
faut maintenant qu'on soit capable de
dire que la sobriété c'est pas le mot de
la rentrée c'est pas une mode c'est pas
une tendance et j'ajoute que Elisabeth
borne au même université d'été du Medef
a dit ne vous inquiétez pas la sobriété
ne veut pas dire la décroissance donc on
peut avoir un débat sémantique ça peut
être très intéressant comme sujet sur
est-ce qu'il faut parler de décroissance
et ce qu'il faut parler de post
croissance mais je crois que le message
politique qui est adressé au patronat ce
jour-là c'est ne vous inquiétez pas on
va on va pas venir vous embêter et on va
vous laisser faire de la croissance de
l'hyper croissance des investissements
fossiles des investissements où vous
voulez comme vous le souhaitez et donc
là on a quand même un gros problème de
message politique justement on parle du
message politique on parle du patronat
on parle là des élites mais quid de
l'opinion publique c'est quand même un
sujet qui concerne tous les Français
tous les Français ont compris qu'on
était face aux grands défis du
dérèglement climatique pourquoi les
Français ne s'emparent pas de ce sujet
on les a vu défiler pendant des mois
contre la réforme des retraites pourquoi
ces manifestations par exemple de jeunes
tous les vendredis n'ont pas pris plus
d'ampleur selon vous peut-être Matthew
Goa tient sur sur ce sur ce thème en
fait on a de la difficulté de convaincre
en fait oui mais en fait il y a des
effets dans l'opinion depuis 10-15 ans
c'est à dire qu'on a vu les grandes
masses le climato scepticisme reculait
plutôt alors le climato-scepticisme pur
c'est à dire est-ce que l'homme est
responsable du réchauffement climatique
ça c'est la question pour repérer les
climatosceptiques après les grandes
canicules de 2019 avec le record en
France de 46 degrés de 2022
les gens qui répondaient c'est pas la
faute de l'homme sont autour de 15 20%
en France ça existe encore et c'est pas
du tout marginal mais il y avait
vraiment un moment dans l'opinion de
dire aux Français et ben maintenant vous
pensez que c'est la faute de l'homme
vous êtes convaincu parce que disent les
scientifiques du GIEC qu'est-ce qu'on
fait c'est ça l'importance du discours
politique aussi et en fait comme le
discours politique concret avec un récit
avec un une projection 2030 2040 2050
n'est pas beaucoup arriver ou alors une
distanciation vis-à-vis du monde
politique de la part des jeunes qui font
les marges pour le climat qui croit
beaucoup qui croient beaucoup dans des
mouvements horizontaux plutôt que dans
des mouvements verticaux qui ne croient
plus dans les parties ils se sont
retrouvés je pense qu'ils croient
beaucoup mais ils sont à côté des
parties donc on a une sorte de
distanciation entre le monde politique
ancien ou institutionnel et le
militantisme climatique
vous interrompre mais mais une fracture
interne ce que vous citiez des chiffres
sur le climato-scepticisme dernier en
publié fin juillet donc c'est très
récent on a quand même 8 % des Français
qui n'illent l'existence du
réchauffement climatique 8% et quand
même 29% qui ne lui reconnaissent pas
une origine humaine et là on est dans
une progression c'est plus 8 points en
trois ans donc ça c'est quand même je
veux bien vous entendre là-dessus parce
que ça contredit un tout petit peu ce
que vous disiez c'est vrai ça peut être
j'avais pas vu cette enquête là parce
que effectivement je me demandais cet
automne comment ça allait réagir par
rapport à ce qu'on s'est dit sur l'été
mitigés etc la météo a de l'influence
sur l'opinion pendant un été ce que je
voulais dire c'est qu'il y a un risque
de
climato-scepticisme oui il existe et
s'ils renforce c'est toujours dramatique
il y a un risque de climato relativisme
aussi c'est-à-dire la marche peut
paraître tellement haute quand elle
n'est pas accompagnée par des récits
politiques ou par des aides et des
choses très concrètes qu'on peut dire
bon il y a un réchauffement climatique
c'est peut-être de la faute de l'homme
mais en tout cas
on s'y habituera de fil en aiguille
l'humanité c'est toujours adapté ce qui
m'a tout relativisme peut exister dans
l'opinion il est très difficile à
mesurer parce qu'il faut poser les
bonnes questions allez-y Flora je vous
donne un apport juste pourquoi l'opinion
n'est toujours pas massivement convaincu
moi je crois que évidemment on est en
démocratie et c'est l'opinion qui fait
la pluie et le beau temps de l'action
politique plus que jamais peut-être avec
le système d'information qu'on a
aujourd'hui je crois quand même que on
n'a pas la même responsabilité quand on
est un électeur ou quand on est le
patron d'une entreprise du CAC 40 ou
quand on est un patron quand on est
quand on est journaliste aussi
d'ailleurs quand on est un journaliste
et je crois que quand on inspire à
certaines responsabilités à certaines
fonctions excusez-moi je vais employer
le terme élite qui est par un mot à la
mode mais il y a aussi une une volonté
d'appartenir à l'élite qui doit guider
le peuple et je crois que c'est beaucoup
plus grave un chef d'entreprise qui
nie certaines réalités climatiques que
un citoyen et quand on regarde le nombre
de climato-sceptiques qui restent etc
on peut un peu te faire tout dire aux
chiffres parce qu'il y a aussi un
chiffre qui montre que 85% des Français
sont prêts à changer radicalement de
mode de vie pour sauver la planète
quand on arrive au moment où il faut
vraiment changer le modèle la bataille
elle est plus scientifique parce que
tous ceux qui veulent écouter on les
informations apportées de main la
bataille elle est informationnelle elle
est politique et elle est surtout de la
responsabilité de qui a envie de guider
ce pays et comment alors on va en parler
parce qu'il y a une planification
écologique qu'on attend depuis la
campagne électorale d'Emmanuel Macron
pour sa réélection elle devrait être
annoncée d'ici 15 jours en tout cas
c'est ce que nous a promis le ministre
Christophe Béchu on y reviendra mais
dans ce que vous me dites moi je retiens
deux choses parce qu'il y a le
complotisme ou le scepticisme face aux
vérités scientifiques ils concernent pas
seulement le climat donc il y a il y a
ça d'un côté mais de l'autre il y a
aussi Jean José je sais pas comment vous
vous analysez voilà c'est c'est huit
points perdus on va dire sur ce terrain
en trois ans est-ce que c'est parce que
on commence justement dans les actions
des politiques ou de certaines
entreprises à arriver dans le dur
c’est-à-dire que il y a des décisions
qui ont été prises on doit changer de
comportement dans le dur et on arrive
dans libidence c'est à dire que
justement des gens souhaitent nier
l'évidence pour parce que quand même
accepter la réalité le réchauffement
climatique c'est une certaine façon et
la responsabilité humaine c'est d'une
certaine façon
s'engager accepter de s'engager c'est
d'ailleurs ce que vous dites mais voilà
pour le climatisation scepticisme il y a
quand même encore une présence très
forte d'une communauté scepticisme sur
les réseaux sociaux et ça c'est sa
maison ça interroge par rapport aux
jeunes qui s'alimentent largement sur
les réseaux sociaux et c'est très
présent alors moi l'analyse que je fais
par rapport à votre question pourquoi
c'est quand même parce que c'est notre
vie de tous les jours Thomas disons se
loger se nourrir se déplacer ce sont les
deux tiers des émissions en France et ça
c'est notre vie de tous les jours et
chacun d'entre nous on peut se regarder
y compris moi-même d'ailleurs je ne
dirais pas le contraire c'est les
questions qu'il faut se poser c'est pas
si facile de modifier son comportement
disons son comportement le comportement
de sa famille dans toute ce qui fait
notre vie
et ça c'est un obstacle
économique le coût économique des disons
de ne pas lutter contre l'échauffement
climatique et tout ce qui est très
important et je crois on va pas disons
je crois qu'à mon tout le cette
transition c'est alors on va pas parler
de décroissance ou de croissance mais
c'est pour moi synonyme de dynamisme
économique c'est ça qui est important
c'est le dynamisme économique oui parce
que effectivement c'est c'est une vraie
question mais je préfère qu'on la traite
un peu plus tard dans dans l'émission
sur les les mesures de transformation
elles ont un coût c'est évident pour les
États pour les entreprises mais
peut-être que ça va on peut dire
aujourd'hui c'est un boulet mais ça va
peut-être devenir un argument presque de
compétitivité je voudrais qu'on en parle
un peu plus tard parce que là on est un
peu dans le constat dans cette première
partie de de débat et je voudrais qu'on
parle des conséquences de des canicules
plus globalement de la chaleur sur la
santé je propose à Tam traduit de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
bonsoir table bienvenue bonsoir sur ce
nouveau plateau de sens public si vous
nous n'étiez pas avec nous hier voilà on
a ce nouveau décor qui est qui est
magnifique plus chaleureux et plus
ouvert sur le monde grâce à nos écrans
donc on va parler des conséquences sur
la santé est-ce qu'on a des chiffres et
peut-être à quel point la chaleur est
meurtrière en France il y a une étude de
santé publique France qui a été publié
au mois de juin dernier elle a étudié
l'impact de la chaleur sur la mortalité
en France de 2014 à 2022 et en voici
quelques chiffres éloquents tout d'abord
sur l'ensemble de cette période et bien
près de 33000 décès sont attribuables à
la chaleur ça a été mesuré entre le 1er
juin et le 15 septembre de chaque année
parmi ces décès et bien près d'un tiers
ont été observés pendant les canicules
au sommet de ce triste palmarès la
canicule de 2022 près de 7000 décès en
excès ou encore celle de 2019 avec 4500
morts en plus en 2019 les canicules
c'est tout simplement l'événement
climatique extrême associé au plus lourd
far humain explique l'étude mais les
jours chauds en dehors des canicules
nous exposent aussi à des risques
importants est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
comment on peut recenser les morts liés
à la chaleur là c'est vraiment là la
difficulté ce n'est pas du tout simple
il y a d'abord ce que vous pouvez
effectivement recenser ce sont des rares
cas où le lien avec la chaleur est très
claire dans certaines maladies comme
l'hyperthermie le coup de chaud la
déshydratation ou même l'hyponatrémie
c'est ce que j'ai appris lors de cette
chronique c'est l'hyper hydratation
quand on se hydrate trop et qu'on a plus
assez de sel dans le sang vous recensez
aussi bien par exemple les accidents
mortels liés au travail quelle est la
mécanique les fortes chaleurs elles
engendrent de la fatigue une diminution
de la vigilance de la capacité cognitive
ce qui augmente le risque d'accident à
cela il faut ajouter ce que vous pouvez
estimer en comparant une année avec
canicule à la même période sans canicule
et qui permet aussi d'avoir une idée de
la surmortalité c'est de plus en plus
difficile quand il y a des canicules qui
s'enchaînent bien sûr la chaleur peut
aussi graver des pathologies existantes
par exemple cardiaque respiratoires
vasculaire rénale et puis enfin il y a
le combo qu'on a notamment observé cette
année mais surtout l'année dernière le
combo chaleur pluie sécheresse orage qui
peut aussi occasionner de nouvelles
pathologies je vous donne un exemple là
dingue en explosion l'an dernier avec la
prolifération en France du moustique
tigre en 2002 2022 a été une année
exceptionnelle un 66 cas de dingue
autochtones recensés c'est-à-dire que la
maladie a été contractée en France
métropolitaine pourquoi je dis que c'est
une explosion et bien parce que quand on
observe l'évolution c'est flagrant il y
avait eu seulement 50 cas autochtones
recensés en tout entre 2006 et 2021
alors justement on va terminer là dessus
on s'est dit qu'il fallait dézoomer pour
bien comprendre le le phénomène si on
regarde ce que la chaleur fait plus de
mort aujourd'hui qu'hier mais on observe
depuis les années 70 deux phénomènes
opposés une température moyenne très
chaude c'est à dire au-dessus de 28
degrés associés à un risque de décès qui
était plus dans les années 70
qu'aujourd'hui ça s'explique notamment
par l'amélioration de l'état de santé
des Français ou par la meilleure prise
en charge médicale mais ces dernières
années et bien le nombre de jours chauds
a augmenté ce qui a engendré une
augmentation du nombre de décès bref les
progrès sociaux médicaux n'ont pas
compensé le nombre et l'intensité des
vagues de chaleur merci beaucoup Thomas
pour toutes ces explications est-ce que
ce sont des
cette dimension là on va dire sanitaire
de de canicules est-ce que c'est intégré
par de plus en plus par les DRH vous qui
conseillez les entreprises
pas vraiment non parce que parce que
vous remarquerez que les chiffres qu'on
voit là ils sont pas ils sont
inquiétants mais ils sont pas
terrorisants c'est à dire que on n'est
pas enfin moi je trouve ça terrorisant
évidemment et vous aussi autour de ce
plateau quand même mais je veux dire ça
fait pas sursauter comme quand il y a
l'arrivée de la pandémie de covid et
qu'on voit des images de de en Chine de
personnes en habillées de combinaison
blanche je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
question c'est quoi le bon argument pour
convaincre un chef d'entreprise qui doit
parfois même faire pivoter son modèle
économique parce que c'est de ça dont on
parle la plupart des entreprises
notamment nous on travaille beaucoup
dans le secteur de la construction ils
ont bien conscience de l'ampleur des
changements qu'ils ont à opérer enfin
peut-être pas tous mais certains de plus
en plus et donc en fait aujourd'hui
toute la question c'est quel sacrifice
de modèles économique et
quel bras de fer avec l'actionnariat ils
sont prêts à mener et on se rappelle
quand même tous du cas Emmanuel Faber
qui chez Danone déjà essayé d'aller un
peu plus loin que les autres et qui est
pas resté qui est pas resté en poste
c'est pour ça que même si nous moi mon
action professionnelle se fait aux côtés
des patrons des dirigeants c'est quand
même de l'action politique qu'on attend
les règles et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que le marché européen c'est le plus
grand marché du monde donc en fait il
faut arrêter de penser que on n'a pas
les leviers économiques qu'on appelle
les leviers de pression internationale à
notre disposition alors il faudrait
causer l'élections européennes les
candidats de l'écologie politique
soit un peu plus majoritaire que
aujourd'hui on n'y est pas exactement
mais en fait à un moment c'est par les
urnes que que on va trouver les
solutions et j'entendais Patrick Martin
le patron du Medef réagir après votre
petite votre petit commentaire et dire
il faut que nous soyons réalistes mais
en fait le réalisme il est pas du côté
du patronat il est du côté des
scientifiques qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
d'être réaliste et donc on ne peut pas
arrêter d'investir massivement dans les
énergies fossiles parce que ce serait
pas réaliste c'est pas possible et en
fait pourquoi il prononce cette phrase
Patrick Martin parce que quand on est
patron on se représente le patronat
aujourd'hui
alors ça dépend comment on se positionne
quand on est Patrick Martin aujourd'hui
on a une idée en tête c'est la
compétition la compétition
internationale la compétition entre les
entreprises et donc on va dire bah oui
c'est vrai on va se désinvestir par
exemple du projet de pipeline en Ouganda
ECOP mais il y a une entreprise chinoise
il y a une entreprise américaine qui va
récupérer le projet et c'est pas faux et
donc c'est un vrai argument et donc
aujourd'hui le vrai sujet c'est que on a
un revers de la mondialisation qui nous
revient en plein dans la figure qui est
de se dire bah en fait on a des règles
de compétition internationale qui nous
empêche de bouger moi je suis pas
d'accord parce que je pense que
typiquement le marché européen est un
levier en fait quand on veut on a quand
même des leviers
de savoir de début décembre à Dubaï
justement parce que c'est à Dubaï aussi
de savoir si
tous les pays du monde arrivent à se
mettre d'accord sur une date de fin
d'exploitation du pétrole de dire à
cette année cette année-là à cette
perspective là on arrête tous ensemble
c'est évidemment c'est un des plus
grands défis diplomates bien sûr mais en
attendant en attendant
en attendant on peut effectivement
entendre l'argument qui consiste à dire
en France on a un géant mondial dans
secteur est-ce que il faut lui
saborder le boulot vous voyez ce que je
veux dire parce que c'est un peu ça
c'est un peu ça l'enjeu peut-être un mot
là-dessus et je vous ai juste après
c'est pour ça que c'est c'est ça ne peut
pas être décidé par un pays il faut que
chaque pays avance de son côté avec il y
a des objectifs en France on pourrait y
revenir avec la planification écologique
et là c'est l'importance de la
diplomatie climatique c'est-à-dire là
vraiment c'est le politique au niveau
mondial
pour contre certaines entreprises voilà
mais je pense que ça parfaitement des
termes employés aussi bien papa il peut
y aller que par Patrick Martin sont très
claires on va prendre notre temps la
transition pendant du temps il faut être
réaliste et ça ça nous emmène vers 3
degrés dans la deuxième partie de ce
siècle c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de redire et si
aujourd'hui qu'on décide on a deux fois
trop d'émissions en 2030 par rapport à
ce qu'il faudrait alors je pense que
effectivement total peut jouer un rôle
il développe le renouvelable tout ça
c'est vrai mais ça ne va pas assez vite
il aurait été quand même plus
intelligent d'écouter la communauté
scientifique il y a une vingtaine
d'années mais ça c'est un autre problème
mais bien sûr on peut toujours dire il
faut être réaliste on y arrivera pas ça
veut dire qu'on va vers 3 degrés c'est
bien ça quand disons le marché et ça on
voit bien que bon voilà on commence à
parler de
de région invivable donc on en parlait
disons comme une hypothèse et les mois
dernier bien en Iran il y a disons toute
activité a été arrêté pendant deux ou
trois jours parce que il y avait des
températures au-delà de 50 degrés et ça
on va y arriver donc il faut bien
comprendre c'est pas un jeu on dirait
disons on va ralent c'était ça l'idée je
sais très bien que c'est pas facile et
que c'est même très difficile peut-être
un peu cible mais notre rôle de
scientifique c'est de dire hérodire que
si on prend notre temps si on est
réaliste comme le dit Patrick Martin et
bien nous allons dans le mur nous allons
vers trois degrés dans la deuxième
partie de ce siècle et c'est maintenant
qu'il faut agir c'est pas c'est bien sûr
la prochaine décennie également mais
vous voyez bien c'est le message qui est
clair et donc cette question de la
planification écologique effectivement
est-ce qu'elle sera à la hauteur de
cette urgence climatique on le saura je
le disais tout à l'heure dans deux
semaines le pré dans la République a
donné des pistes hier lors de son
interview à Hugo travers il intervie de
diffuser sur Tik Tok et sur Youtube on
écoute un extrait en particulier sur
notre objectif forêt je vous l'annonce
là c'est un point hyper important je
veux que on est dès la sixième de cette
année qu'on commence à avoir des élèves
qui plantent des arbres et qu'on est
cette génération où chaque collégien
aura planté son arbre on n'arrivera pas
je pense à le faire pour l'intégralité
des 6e mais si on a chaque génération
qui tourne son âme ils vont nous aider à
aller à notre milliard de reboisement
c'est hyper important
Laetitia cette phrase elle tourne en
boucle a été beaucoup moquée oui elle a
été beaucoup moquée et c'est des
tracteurs d'Emmanuel Macron et du
gouvernement de l'exécutif ça sent
emparés pourquoi parce que ils ont dit
que finalement c'était une mesurette et
puis que c'était hypocrite parce que en
attendant il y a beaucoup de projets où
il y a la battage d'arbres centenaire
par exemple l'autoroute a69 des platanes
sont sacrifiées bon d'accord mais quid
de l'intervention de l'État dans des
mesures qui sont souvent décidées
notamment pour l'abattage de ces arbres
des platanes au niveau du de la
municipalité voir du département
a sorti cette petite phrase de un élève
a planter son arme quand il sera en 6e
dans un développement de 30 minutes je
me suis tout repassé ce matin j'ai
minuté le temps de l'intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron sur l'écologie 30
minutes alors oui cette mesure bien sûr
est symbolique mais elle n'est pas
anecdotique il me semble qu'elle
participe de la prise de conscience
collective vous le voyez vous nous
l'avez dit encore aujourd'hui qui est
urgente surtout pour les générations
futures et finalement cette mesure de
plantana mais il l'avait déjà évoqué il
a dit en octobre dernier en octobre 2022
il avait dit il y aura un milliards
d'arbres d'ici la fin de la décennie et
donc ce qui nous a appris juste dit que
les collégiens les mettre la main à la
pâte donc c'est pas comme on a pu
l'entendre une mesure écolo des années
90 non c'est une mesure symbolique la
plus symbolique certainement dans un
développement encore une fois de 30
minutes sur un futur plan vous l'avez
dit Thomas qui va être présenté par
Elisabeth Borre dans l'attend tous ce
plan de cette planification écologique
ça doit arriver dans dans les jours à
venir et d'ailleurs ça a été déjà été
présenté aux associations et aux ONG
donc peut-être vous avez eu quelques
quelques grandes lignes
il a parlé d'une généralisation des
pompes à chaleur de l'électrification à
rénovation en thermique avec des aides
publiques pour ceux qui ont besoin de
faire des travaux et des contraintes
pour les propriétaires et il a aussi
parlé de la rénovation des patiscolaires
justement qui qui sont touchés de plein
fouet par la canicule et puis puisqu'on
détaille un peu les mesures se passent
transport en commun et rail quoi oui
modèle allemand c'est vrai qu'il y aura
un pass à tarif unique on pourra prendre
le TER de la région et puis prendre les
transports en commun aussi alors ça ça
va être un peu plus compliqué c'est le
ministre des Transports qui est en
charge d'en discuter avec les régions
parce qu'il faut que les régions aussi
soit favorable à ce plan donc vous le
voyez finalement cette initiative d'un
arbre pour chaque élève de 6e était noyé
dans un ensemble de mesures on est même
allé jusqu'au développement de
l'hydrogène c'est vous dire pour les
avions donc on a été loin hier dans
cette interview d'Emmanuel Macron face à
travers je peux pas faire la mer la
morale
cette intention là mais parfois il est
utile quand même de retourner à la
Source d'écouter l'intégralité du
l'interview 2h4 pour les courageux pour
pouvoir se faire une opinion critique
pour pouvoir critiquer ensuite Mathieu
Guard quand même est-ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron force un peu sa nature quand il
mêle la planification écologique au
sommet des préoccupations en tout cas
c'est le sentiment qui va qui va vouloir
donner dans les prochains dans les
prochains jours sur ce qu'il considère
réellement c'est un sondage parce que
voilà tous ces proches disent qu'il a
quand même une réelle conviction
climatique ce qui est sûr c'est que le
climat est revenu la force dans la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron dans
l'entre-deux tour de la présidentielle
2022 où il dit mon premier second
quinquennat sera écologique ou ne sera
pas et le climat c'est le combat du
siècle c'était un très beau discours qui
a été très écouté notamment par ses
proches et par son entourage certains
ont dit il veut juste attirer les voix
de la gauche c'est l'entre-deux tours
etc force et de constater qu'il a mis en
place l'architecture de la planification
et c'est important dans un pays aussi
administré de la France un secrétaire
général la planification écologique qui
depuis des mois travaillent et le
travail d'un SGP comme ça c'est de faire
les trajectoires d'émissions de CO2
jusqu'en 2030 et tout est entre les
mains de l'Elysée et de batillon ce qui
va amener ce plan de planification en
gros il s'agit de réduire de 50% de nos
émissions par rapport à ce qu'on
émettait en 1990 la marche chez les
parents franchissable du tout une chose
c'est que le climat pourrait être le
retour de la grande politique la
politique dans un sens churchillien du
terme c'est à dire on fait le constat de
choses très graves potentiellement
dramatique et après on agit
Macron n'a pas porté le récit de
l'écologie politique depuis un an il n'a
pas accompagné le travail du sgpe ça a
été décalé à plusieurs raisons à
plusieurs reprises pardon pour des
bonnes raisons parce qu'il y avait des
actualités dramatiques en France les
émeutes début juillet où ils ont dû
reporter leur conseil de planification
écologique mais en fait pour embarquer
toute la société toutes ces mesures sont
très très importantes il y a aussi un
discours et un récit politique à mener
c'est pas ce qui met en avant
la plupart du temps pour que juste pour
terminer rapidement il y a eu un
traumatisme des gilets jaunes dans
toutes bien sûr cet ensemble du
macronisme qui est de dire on s'empare
de la vie quotidienne des gens on essaye
de voilà les arbres et ça c'est très
très important mais de ne pas emmerder
les Français entre guillemets et ça ça
rejoint la question de poser Laetitia
tout à l'heure ça rejoint le sondage que
dans je les détails tout à l'heure quand
même pourquoi pourquoi c'est important
notamment toujours pour le milieu
économique
Flora gibbaly d'avoir une planification
écologique est-ce que ça peut permettre
au chef d'entreprise d'anticiper parce
que c'est ça vous imaginez que ce qui
est en question dans cette affaire c'est
pas un tableau Excel de bilan carbone ça
y est les entreprises le font c'est de
se demander comment on se nourrit
comment on se vêtit comment on se
chauffe comment on se déplace voilà et
comment on vit voilà c'est quand même
existentielle et donc on pourrait avoir
un récit économique un narratif
économique tout à fait fertile vous
imaginez on va voir les jeunes en école
de commerce qui veulent devenir
entrepreneur et on leur dit c'est simple
vous vous devez réinventer exactement
comment les Français se nourrissent
allez-y vous avez une feuille blanche il
y a des contraintes on va vous donner
les contraintes et vous allez réinventer
la façon dont on doit se déplacer c'est
très fertile et donc on pourrait avoir
un narratif et je rejoins tout à fait ce
qui a été dit sur le fait que le
président Macron même si au nous on est
à 13 en lien avec le secrétariat général
et la planification écologique et il
faut le dire il faut un très bon travail
le problème c'est toujours le même c'est
la question du portage politique et donc
si Emmanuel Macron avait envie voilà
d'ouvrir un champ d'ouvrir une nouvelle
aire de de d'ouvrir la civilisation
écologique comme c'est le thème de notre
discussion ce soir alors il pourrait
il y a beaucoup de patrons il y a
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui pourraient se
reconvertir si on les accompagnait qui
pourraient suivre une direction mais
c'est quand même bien aujourd'hui ce
sont souvent les règlements les lois qui
ont été votées qui ont accéléré la
mutation des entreprises je rejoins
aussi ce qui a été dit si on revient
même le sur la définition de ce que
c'est gouverner gouverner c'est être
capable de tenir le gouvernail de
prendre une décision quand aujourd'hui
vous voulez prendre une décision
fondatrice civilisationnelle et que vous
avez les émeutes que enfin là on passe
quand même une semaine à parler d'abaya
on passe quand même beaucoup de temps
alors il y a des sujets plus ou moins
importants le pouvoir d'achat évidemment
il y a des sujets qui sont fondamentaux
mais aujourd'hui est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron est en capacité de gouverner de
voir clair devant lui de prendre des
décisions quand toutes les cartes il y a
tout ce qui vient le polluer ça c'est la
société médiatique d'aujourd'hui c'est
un autre débat qui est important mais je
reviens à cette question de
l'acceptabilité on doit vous la poser
souvent aussi je vous aime parce que on
est dans le on parle de changement de
civilisation ou de modèle économique et
donc c'est forcément douloureux quoi et
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'une partie
des Français qui nous écoutent sont en
train de dire ils sont bien gentils mais
ça va déjà trop vite quoi oui
effectivement je l'ai ressenti ce
sentiment à l'issue de la de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
disons que voilà d'une société j'ai
salué vraiment le la mise en place de du
sacréat général planification il y a pas
de problème j'étais même assez optimiste
enfin j'ai bien aimé de discours de
Manuel Macron mais la réalité on en est
loin puisque d'une certaine façon
Emmanuel Macron a quand même largement
tourné le dos aux propositions faites
par les citoyens donc il y a très peu de
ces propositions qui ont été vraiment
repris sérieusement dans la loi le 110
km/h on en a la plus parlé et même qui
sont on va pas parler de d'Élisabeth
borne qui violent la loi puisque qu'elle
se met des on ne pas prendre l'avion sur
plus de 2h30 donc ça c'est aujourd'hui
on peut quand même se poser des
questions il y a le symbole je suis
d'accord c'est très important j'ai bien
l'idée de tenter un il y a aussi une
exemplaire d'exemplarité de nos
gouvernants qui doivent respecter les
règles qu'il se donne et qu'il nous
donne donc voilà donc moi j'ai vraiment
la crainte et voilà que les mesures
mises en place je souhaiterais qu'on
réussisse au moins 50% en 2030 il y a
pas de problème mais j'ai la crainte
qu'on n'en prennent pas le chemin le
Haut Conseil pour le climat nous dit
qu'il faut vraiment doubler largement de
ces moins 6% par an qu'il faudrait faire
d'ici 2030 donc c'est loin d'être gagné
et je pense je l'ai dit que si les
mesures proposées par les citoyens avait
été mise en place plus complètement et
bien on n'en serait pas là on serait sur
une meilleure trajectoire et mais on
voit bien pour revenir à votre question
Thomas c'est que c'est une question
d'acceptabilité que nous a dit Emmanuel
Macron on était dans le disons le jardin
d'élysée je ne veux pas cette mesure 110
km/h parce que les gens ne vont pas
l'accepter ça a été le point de départ
de ces décisions merci beaucoup à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat Florian je
rappelle le titre de votre livre le
syndrome de la fourmi qui est publié aux
éditions de l'Observatoire à très
bientôt sur sur public c'est